regarde bonjour, je suis Emmett, je vais
juste sortir, je n'ai aucune idée de ce qui se
passe chez tous mes collègues
maîtres d'œuvre, y compris, mais sans s'y
limiter, Superman Wonder Woman la
sirène ninja verte 1980-quelque chose
gars de l'espace Michelangelo Michelangelo et le
2002  All-stars de la NBA, nous avons appris que les
affaires de Lord prévoient de mettre fin au monde tel que
nous le connaissons, il y a encore un espoir que la
spéciale soit apparue, je pense que je l'ai compris, mais
juste au cas où, dites-moi tout à
nouveau, je n'écoutais pas
je '
je flippe détendez-vous tout le monde je suis ici pac-man oh mon
pouce pourriez-vous en faire un en
orange je ne travaille qu'en noir et
parfois en gris très très foncé
hey palette je déteste vous dire ça mais
je ne pense pas que vous '  Je suis censé être là et
bien oui je vais devoir te signaler
e
ah non attends avec nous